now to a frustrating situation for
thousands of americans trying to go on
vacation and for people like tony
traveling to and from l.a for his wife's
book event we're talking about thousands
of passengers stranded in part because
of staffing issues for airlines in the
air and on the ground elise preston is
at new jersey's newark liberty airport
at least there were some big big
problems over the weekend
absolutely frustrating nate good morning
to you within the past 72 hours more
than 14 000 flights have been canceled
or delayed here at newark 40 flights
have been grounded already just this
morning this as airports across the
country are desperate to get back on
schedule
understaffed airports and airlines are
being slammed and it's taking a toll on
travelers at this point i don't have any
high hopes we're talking 10 hours more
than 900 flights were canceled on sunday
alone delta getting hit the hardest with
more than 200 cancellations
delta apologized saying in a statement a
variety of factors continue to impact
our operations including challenges with
air traffic control weather and
unscheduled absences canceling a flight
is always our last resort since the
start of june u.s airports have seen an
average of 2.2 million flyers every day
they didn't tell them why it was
canceled but they canceled everybody's
flight the industry has been struggling
receiving tens of billions in federal
aid since the start of the pandemic
transportation secretary pete buda judge
met with airline executives right before
the weekend telling them to stick to
their flight schedules and to hire more
customer service agents giving them
until the 4th of july weekend to do
better or face potential fines cbs news
senior travel advisor peter greenberg
you can hire as many customer service
agents as you want to say i'm sorry but
if you don't fix the root problems the
apologies will continue you got to be
able to find pilots there's a shortage
you have to be able to find people who
work under the wing ground handlers
baggage loaders until staffing increases
as a whole greenberg expects more
disruptions through september
now after that meeting with airline
executives secretary buda judge had his
own flight canceled he had to drive from
washington d.c to new york now some tips
to keep in mind for your own air travel
try to book the first flight out and
arrive at least three hours early tony
oh boy elise thank you very much nate
since you brought it up i did try to
travel this week and had a flight
canceled on friday two hour delay on
saturday and a three-hour delay on
sunday so what was supposed to be a
pleasure trip a little bit of book tour
involved with just work work work were
you in a good mood when you got there uh
no
so frustrating i know i know it was
tough it was time i missed all father's
day actually i got home it was dark all
the kids were asleep my grandma had made
some cards i i had to greet them in the
dark oh my god a lot of dad's nuts we're
glad you're back even though it took a
while yeah thanks guys